- But about maybe five days ago,
I realized I'm coming to Denver
to interview the wrong person.
I should be interviewing your mascot,
- Rocky?
- who we all learned apparently is making,
like, $600,000 a year.
Did you see that report?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- So what makes Rocky
the superior NBA mascot?
- He just gives off a lot of energy
and makes the half-court shots backwards
every time.
Actually at a really good rate.
And, yeah.
Yeah. He just does a great job. Great energy.
- So do you know the man or woman
inside of Rocky?
- Mmhmm.
- OK.
What's he or she like?
- Uh, that's confidential.
- Really? Is this top-secret?
- Yeah. That's how it goes.
- Is the identity not revealed?
- Nah.
- Does anyone know Rocky?